Nation
so parental alienation is when
a mother or a parent sorry forcibly
alienates the child from the parent
and willingly and you know purposely
turns that child against
um the other parent and I think a lot of
the times like the chat was saying
[Music]
a lot of the time we don't get the other
parents side of the story okay and then
we grow up and then we hear that side
and in my in my experience
I have three people in my life three men
in my life who were fathers who all went
through parental alienation
um do you know anybody who has actually
been alienated from their from their
parents
yeah
yeah
yeah
the guy I was talking about funny enough
him
he's he's been in a situation where he
was uh he's with a girl he's had a child
they were both in her committed
relationship and
for some reason not to my knowledge it
didn't work out now in frustration of
the relationship
they've gone for a bit of core battle
right now in um trying to obtain rights
to
visiting rights and and so forth the
problem he's facing is the fact that
she's she's not she's not British and
she has whatever he means
stated that she wants to leave the
country and of the mistake of the past
because it's another baby mum he's not
looking to make that same mistake ever
again so
in contrast to um everything you're
saying this is exactly what he's going
through and
fortunately I say fortunate because the
sun is so young
not able to really understand what's
going on
I truly believe that's his Saving Grace
because had it been all that it would
have been a lot worse for him due to the
character of the woman and then from
what I understand he's going through
right now
all the lies that's being told against
him future thinks more likely to
alienate the child
evil yeah 100 because I think it's
because it goes to the fact that
resentment could be held in a different
way from women than it can be for men
and
women know that physically they can't
hurt they can't hear a man well they can
but they can't overcome a man with
strength so the way they get at him is
is an emotional way and ways that they
possibly may not be able to control
external factors
assets possession divorce
children these are external factors from
a relationship that happen and
it seems like
in order to get the get back for any you
know resentment the woman may have for a
child is always coming out in external
factors such as a child and most of the
time what do we do when that happens to
us to men we kill ourselves or we kill
them or we just don't do nothing and
give all our money away they walk away
from it they even just like the response
just walk away from total responsibility
try to fight for the responsibility or
turn crazy men men are eight times more
likely to kill themselves after a
divorce when they don't get the kids
yeah yeah and this is not spoken of and
this is what I was this goes back to my
point of the importance of Father these
things ain't spoken of because of the
society the guy in such a society we
live in everything is catered to
feelings
and not facts or logic I like to stay on
on the on the side of logic and fact
when it comes to these things because
this is this is life at hand this is not
it's not something to play with it's
it's life is our future generations and
future Society so when we play with
these things on emotions that change
daily
just to cater to wonder it's it's very
harmful for not just the men the child
in the future
people and and Men there's a lot of men
that go broke trying to get their kids
back too and they'll be drained through
like legal fees to the point where they
do sign away their rights but it's not
because they don't want to be in the
kids they just are running out of money
and and it's like
and then they can go to especially in
the US like you can go to jail if you
don't pay taxes yeah but when but the
government pays women to be
single mothers
so to to answer the person that um that
said like I might have been alienated by
my mother I understand why you would say
that
um most of the time women do try to
alienate their kids from their mother
fortunately for me
it's been quite the opposite my mother
always kind of encouraged me to go and
meet him
um I've been lucky
from the beginning of my teenage years
I've been lucky that um my mother found
a stepdad for me and uh he he filled in
he filled in the role quite well but
even before that I have met my father
um and he had the opportunity my mother
did not you know like limit his access
to me he had the opportunity I told him
like I want you to be in my life but I
was a child I expected him to make the
first move
um and he he just wouldn't and now to
the to the other person that said maybe
I should meet him no I shouldn't because
he he blatantly refused to be to be in
my life and now that I'm
I'm quite made I'm I find myself that
like I'm
I got to be more successful than you
know than him I I don't think that I
should suddenly look him out
suddenly make him like uh make him proud
of me or no he doesn't deserve that he
had the chance
my mother my mother gave him the chance
my mother encouraged me to give him the
chance I just wanted him to make the
first move now I understand that you
know my situation is
a bit different like a lot of people
a lot of people's fathers want to be in
their child and to be honest I wish that
my dad made an effort maybe then not
maybe surely then I would have I would
have totally
you know hung out with him bonded with
him it just didn't happen do you know
what listening to you
um
and the way in which you speak to your
father
um mirrors my life a little bit so it's
very like Airy to hear you speak like
that because I can safely say that I've
only ever hated one person on this
planet
and that was my father well I don't hate
him no I'm not saying you do but I'm
saying the way in which you speak and
like that resentment like he doesn't
deserve it
um and I get it you know I get it
because I've definitely been there
[Music]
um
but I would say that when I was like in
my 20s I had all the resentment for this
man like literally if I saw him on the
street I knew that I would try and get
into a fight with him like that's the
way I didn't
um that's the way I didn't love him and
um just hearing you speak it's kind of
it should be like a
a message to mothers and a message to
fathers also an admission to society to
say that fathers are really needed in
this Society because you know they are
really creating a fatherless Society
creates broken men when you when you
have a kid
like as a child I don't care that you
two don't get along make it work make it
work it's not about you anymore
it's about it's about
your grandchildren not even me it's
about you instilling in me values you
want your grandchildren to be my mother
like I now have with my step step dad
shout out to the stepdad
um
now
uh I have a little brother and sister I
I don't want a kid
my my dad
dealt himself out of a grandchild
and um would you say it's because of
your experience with your dad
it
there's a multiple factors here like the
social the social standards also have a
factor in it like I don't want to
yeah
I'm not in a position to have a child
not emotionally not financially not
socially
um it's not worth it for me and maybe
it's going to be worth it for my little
brother or my little sister if we make
all the all the necessary changes now to
bring families together
maybe then it's going to be worth it for
them
but I feel that I've I've missed my
chance
I don't want to be
to bring a child when
I don't know what's the best way to
raise that child because I don't have a
good example you know when you you
become one nobody knows that to be
fathers by you think about that new he
fooling you you know how hard it is to
raise me I need to die twice I wonder
what he didn't beat me you'd know when
you know you'd not only answers come on
if you have good intentions in life
you're a good person you love you ever
been Loved Before you tend to love
someone you will end up loving someone
you it's just normal this isn't almost
people that want to be fathers they're
going to be fathers and they'll love
their children if somebody don't want to
they're not going to and then the ones
that can only be neglected guess what
they're gonna do grow up in the 2025
what about the 12 that my son goes to
school with a child that hasn't got no
father and that child start beating my
son up what do I do then do I beat that
child up can I find this father to talk
to him I can't what do I do my child
becomes a victim and then when it's 15
16 it kills my son well then things like
that happen to people all the time just
for genuine neglect of children yeah
variety of consequences how can I bring
a child knowing that like I can't do
anything about something like that
happening but you know it's kind of
admirable for him to admit he's not in
the best position to to to bring a child
in the world because a lot of people
just
shrink with their dicks and then end up
producing children that they can't so if
he if he if he has enough
self-reflection and the cognitive mind
to know he's not in the best position to
bring a child in the world I respect
that more than a man who has absolutely
no resources to give a child and brings
it into the world
so I don't think when it comes to
children as much to do with love because
it's more to do with Duty
because love Fades believe me what I'm
trying to say is you've had a lot I said
believe me
[Laughter]
what would be what did you have a
relationship with your father me yeah
the best relationship
almost always had a really love
my dad anything I wanted I got it I just
know like anything if anything happened
he'd always be there to protect me but I
think I've realized an age that a lot of
men that don't come from homes where
they've had like a stable father or um
because they didn't have a stable father
and their mother was single so she was
like busy paying the bills working they
didn't have a father around they find it
a lot more difficult to love in life and
then I think as someone who's grown up
with really loving parents trying to get
love from a man who didn't grow up with
love is a very hard thing to do and it's
probably not going to work out as well
unless that man has taken a bit taken
gone through an experience that's made
him know because I feel like someone who
hasn't received love doesn't know how to
give love as well as someone that has
received love their whole life so I
think as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible